[Musique]
maman
bienvenue sur le plateau data dida des
terres 10 pour un débat sur la turquie
ursula von der leyen privé de sièges
lors d'une rencontre officielle tout le
monde ici a vu un affront à l'égard de
l'europe est une manifestation
supplémentaire du sexisme du président
erdogan
or cette rencontre avait pour but
d'apaiser les tensions avec la turquie
après les concessions faites par son
président sur la grèce et sur chiffres
et bien c'est raté
mais que veut la turquie exactement et
que veut son président est ce que c'est
conciliable avec ce que veut l'europe
amis ou ennemis la turquie pour en
débattre nous avons invité jean-françois
colosimo vous êtes historia éditeur vous
dirigez les éditions du surf
vous présidez l'institut de théologie
orthodoxe saint-serge et vous êtes
l'auteur du livre le sabre et le turban
qui vient de paraître aux éditions du
cerf sur la république turque pour vous
d'atatürk ar doan c'est la même turquie
c'est le même projet nationaliste et
impérialiste ce serait ça aujourd'hui
pour vous le projet de la turquie en
deux mots oui je pense que la turquie
depuis 1923 depuis sa fondation
essayer de combler par une espèce de
course en avant sans angoisse originelle
celle du fait qu'elle aurait pu ne pas
être n'est ce pas ou être réduites un
petit plateau anatolien comme le voulait
le traité de deux sèvres et donc à
l'intérieur on poursuit la construction
quasiment mécanique à d'une identité
assez artificiel au départ un peu moins
artificiel aujourd'hui qui est celle du
turc aux sunnites identité à la fois
poétiques et religieuses
le nouveau turc le turc régénérer devant
quelque sorte réaffirmé sa capacité de
domination à au moins régional un peu
plus si possible et ce turc l'a
évidemment qui s'est construit sur la
destruction de toutes les minorités
ce turc là aujourd'hui il trouve dans
l'islam cet islam que atatürk avait
nationalisé
eh bien erdogan je dirais là où atatürk
nationale il avait nationalisé l'islam
erdogan d'un islamisme la de la nation
et dans le contexte effectivement des et
1930 liens logiques dominantes c'était
le progressisme aujourd'hui c'est
l'islamisme et la turquie continue à
affirmer je dirais son ambition mais qui
comblent en fait une incertitude d'être
très profonde et pour moi la véritable
question c'est de savoir si la turquie
ne naples osera pas demain didier
billion vous vous êtes géopolitologue
directeur adjoint de l'iris spécialiste
de la turquie et du moyen-orient
rédacteur en chef de la revue
internationale et stratégique vous avez
publié plusieurs ouvrages sur la turquie
que ce soit la politique extérieure de
la turquie chez l'harmattan où l'enjeu
turcs chez armand colin
sans oublier votre dernière publication
géopolitique des mondes arabes aux
éditions eyrolles 40 fiches illustrées
pour comprendre le monde
alors c'est quoi pour vous le le projet
de la turquie d'arnaud anne j'ai pas
tout à fait la même car ception la même
compréhension jean françois colossimo
mais peu importe c'est le libre débat
qui nous rassemble ce soir et j'espère
que cela profite pour tout le monde
j'ai un point d'accord avec
jean-françois c'est le fait qu'il y à
une crise existentielle de la turquie
pendant très longtemps dans l'immédiate
les immédiate années qui ont suivi la
fin de l'empiré ottoman parce
qu'évidemment ce pays a été menacé dans
son existence même sur un petit plateau
anatolien
c'étaient les clauses extrêmement
drastique du traité de sèvres et ça a
été une sorte de traumatisme vont se
traiter en réalité ne s'est jamais
appliquée mustafa kemal atatürk à
organiser initiés diriger une lutte de
libération nationale probablement
d'ailleurs la première du 20e siècle
ce qui a permis à la turquie
républicaine de se constituer dans des
frontières qui sont à peu près
identiques à celles d'aujourd'hui avec
eux l'exception de la région du hatay
peut-être qu'ils reviendront nous donc
aujourd'hui la turquie ne joue plus tout
à fait dans la même cour que dans celles
auxquelles elles étaient relégués dans
les années 20
38 même moment de la guerre froide à
l'époque nous étions très contents quand
je dis nous c'est un ou deux majesté les
européens les occidentaux étions très
contents de trouver la turquie parce que
c'était une des lignes de front par
rapport à l'union soviétique la guerre
froide est terminée
l'union soviétique a implosé et depuis
lors la turquie fait partie de ces pays
ce n'est pas le seul d'ailleurs qui ne
se contente plus de jouer en deuxième
catégorie c'est un pays qui s'est
affirmée c'est un pays qui fait partie
du g20 c'est un pays qui est en
négociation certes infiniment compliquée
avec l'union européenne ces tapis qui
fait toujours partie de l'otan donc
c'est un pays qui veut s'affirmer qui
développe une véritable politique d'
influence régionale dont on peut
d'ailleurs contesté tel ou tel aspect là
n'est pas la question à ce stade de la
discussion
mais pour autant je récuse totalement le
fait qu'il ya une sorte de projet
expansionniste de la turquie qui
consisterait à s'imposer ou imposer son
hégémonie sur la région ou alors si tel
était le projet alors ils s'y
prendraient véritablement très mal parce
que je ne vois pas sur quel pays
précisément ils sont parvenus
aujourd'hui à installer leur hégémonie
donc je pense qu'il faut regarder la
tête froide
il faut intégrer le fait que désormais
la turquie est un pays qui encore une
fois veut compter veut comptée à part
pleine et entière dans le jeu des
relations internationales et tout
particulièrement régionales bien
évidemment mais pour autant je pense que
les velléités de domination régionale 1
n'existe pas et quand il ya eu quelques
velléités et je pense à ce qui s'est
passé il ya juste dix ans au moment des
révoltes arabes où le président et
redonne à mon avis a fait une erreur
tactique en voulant privilégier un
partenariat avec les forces de l'islam
politique
en réalité la mouvance des frères
musulmans ce fut un échec total
et aujourd'hui on peut considérer que
cet aspect tactique il a voulu
développer il ya dix ans est totalement
derrière nous alors première question il
ya quand même l'incident du siège
d'ursula von der leyen
alors à qui la faute vous quand vous
regardez ça au président turc eux
aux européens jean françois colossimo
moi je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
reproches très sévère à faire au
président erdogan
mais je crois que lui faire ce reproche
la de manière aussi forte qu'on a pu le
faire
ça montre plutôt je dirais c'est un
indice plus tôt de nos lâchetés plutôt
que reproche véritablement fondée
la vérité c'est que l'europe est en
désordre total lorsqu'elle sort à
l'étranger que la présidence du conseil
européen
incarnée par monsieur michel et la
présidence de la commission européenne a
incarné par madame van der linden si
vous perdez pas cette expression la
télévision se tirent la bourre depuis
toujours pour savoir qui précède l'ordre
dans l'ordre protocolaire s'est
clairement monsieur michel donc l'europe
arrive je dirais en ordre de bataille
interne les turcs à lampard ou seulement
par pas et nous nous agitons à un sortes
de reproches de de sexisme
alors que très sincèrement il ya
d'autres reproches à faire le président
erdogan avait fait arrêter juste la
veille ou l'avant-veille une dizaine
d'amis rocky n'était pas d'accord avec à
sa vision de doubler le canna du
bosphore ça voilà les violations des
droits de l'homme
il est vrai que la turquie est sorti de
la convention d'istanbul qui est censée
protéger les femmes et les enfants des
des violences conjugales
mais je crois que air de galles est un
véritable provocateur s'il avait voulu
provoquer il serait allé un tout petit
peu plus loin disons que peut-être que
le protocole turc s'est servi déshérence
et des ambiguïtés du protocole européen
pour juste coucher au passage l'europe
encore une fois l'essentiel n'est
vraiment pas là et que nous attardions
là dessus montre bien que ne comprend
pas ce qu'est la turquie et deuxièmement
ne comprend pas les problèmes qu'elle a
et les problèmes qu'elles se posent
parlons plutôt des tous les journalistes
les artistes les écrivains etc grand
boris dans les prisons on va en parler
tout de suite néanmoins y est ça fait
couler beaucoup d'encre est d'ores et
déjà sur twitter on voit des des photos
ou lors des présidences du conseil de
l'europe précédent on s'asseyait même
face à erdre ah non on le voit que ce
soit et que jean claude juncker ou avec
donald tusk on s'asseyait de part et
d'autre du président et que si ça n'a
pas été le cas là alors c'est soit c'est
parce que charles michel
le président du conseil européen ne
voulait pas de de ursula von der leyen
ou c'est parce que le président turc eux
ne voulaient pas des recettes cela van
gaal est votre sentiment un didier
billion va écouter sur ce coup je suis
totalement d'accord avec jean françois
colossimo je pense que tu d'abord c'est
un élément totalement secondaire mais
puisque vous nous posez la question il
faut tirer pont moi j'ai regardé à trois
reprises cette fameuse vidéo pour être
bien sûr d'essayer de comprendre ce qui
se passait et c'est vrai que ce que l'on
voit c'est pas trés c'est pas très fair
play
c'est pas très courtois à l'égard de
madame bovary yens mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est de constater
d'ailleurs quand on fait ça avec
attention
c'est que quand monsieur erdogan madame
van der leyen et monsieur michel rentrer
dans la pièce où doit se tenir la
réunion monsieur michel a l'air de se
précipiter pour pouvoir s'asseoir sur le
fauteuil et c'est là où on voit
maintenant dernière qui sonne comme
interloqué alors ce qui m'intéresse moi
c'est les réactions la première le
premier type de réaction
chronologiquement c'est de dire c'est
encore un coup de ardoyne c'est une prof
de sexisme c'est l'islamisme qui ressort
ce mépris pour les femmes première phase
puis deuxième phase assez rapidement il
ya un certain nombre de diplomates y
compris de diplomates français je pense
à à gérard araud notre ancien
ambassadeur aux états unis qui a ramené
un peu d'ordre là-dedans dix ans mais ça
c'est le protocole on n'y peut rien il
n'y a pas de problème de sexisme ou
d'islamistes
il ya des règles protocolaires et gérard
araud souligne d'ailleurs au passage que
la turquie qui est un vieil état qui a
une longue histoire maîtrise
parfaitement les codes protocolaire ce
qui ne semble pas le cas de l'union
européenne qui est une institution ou
tout du moins un projet de facture
beaucoup plus récentes et pierre
troisième étape troisième séquence c'est
les réflexions telles que les a initiés
jean françois colosimo
sur les oreilles les bisbilles qui
existe entre les dirigeants européens
chacun voulant absolument lui même
représenter l'union européenne qui n'en
demande pas tant
je pense qu'il ya une rivalité
fondamentale entre la commission
européenne qui team structure de type
fédéral en pointillés et puis par contre
le conseil européen qui est une
structure intergouvernementale par
définition du point de vue protocolaire
il est clair on ne peut lui contester ou
pas mais c'est dans les traités
européens
c'est dans ce type de rencontre le
président ou la présidente d'ailleurs du
conseil européen qui a la préséance sur
le ou la président de la commission
européenne mais c'est vrai que lors de
réunions précédentes les choses ne se
sont pas déroulées de cette façon mais
visiblement parce que on ne prête qu'aux
riches
il y a en fait deux services
protocolaires européen pour ce type de
réunion
il ya celui lié à la con au conseil
européen qui visiblement était là et a
préparé la réunion
et puis elle services protocolaires de
madame von der leyen dont la président
de la commission européenne qui n'a pas
pris la peine de se déplacer soit disant
à cause des problèmes sanitaires et bien
évidemment les services protocolaires de
monsieur michel en ont profité c'est
pitoyable
en réalité ces petites croyable et jean
françois colossimo dit la turquie on ait
du mal à la comprendre certes mais alors
on a aussi beaucoup de mal à comprendre
quel est le projet de l'union européenne
parce que en réalité le plus important
j'espère que nous allons avoir le temps
d'en discuter
c'est ce qui c'est c'est le fond c'était
en fait le mandat qui présidait à cette
visite commune des deux présidents de la
commission et du conseil
ce qui est finalement assez rare ce
n'est pas exceptionnel mais c'est assez
rare
pourquoi il y avait t-il cette visite
commune mais parce qu'il y avait eu un
conseil européen qui avait précédé cette
visite de quelques jours et qui avait
pris un certain nombre de décisions à
l'égard de la turquie c'est ça qui est
le plus important et ça personne n'en
parle malheureusement mais j'espère que
nous allons avoir le temps de le faire
ensemble
eh bien nous allons en parler tout de
suite mais d'accord ok oui jean françois
non mais je voulais juste dire quand
même puisque là on est un peu dans
l'unanimisme avec notre ami d'hier
le oui quand erdogan veut provoquer à il
n'envoie pas des messages très subtil il
traite angela merkel de nazis à il
réclame à ce que les français placent le
maquereau en asile psychiatrique
ça c'est le véritable erdogan lorsqu'il
provoque donc je pense qu'on est en fait
effectivement face une forme
d'embrouillamini du recours au ps dans
cette affaire mais moi ce qui me choque
profondément
c'est que d'un coup ça serait la preuve
en quelque sorte de la méchanceté
d'erdogan n'est ce pas ce sexisme et
cetera
je crois qu'on est loin de la réalité
est que les réalités sont autrement plus
dur alors juste avant c'est cette
réalité que je voudrais jeux sur
lesquels je voudrais vous interrogez est
ce que c'est une démocratie la turquie
ou est ce que c'est une dictature
puisque en permanence la question est
posée est d'ailleurs de plus en plus
dans les médias français on parle d'art
douane comme d'un dictateur oubliant par
la même occasion quand il ya eu une
tentative de coup d'état contre lui
absolument tous les chefs d'état y
compris le nôtre ont soutenus erdan
justement au prétexte qu'il n'était pas
un dictateur mais qu'il avait été élu
démocratiquement alors aussi bien que la
démocratie ça ne s'arrête pas au vote
néanmoins on reprocha naguère d'ogden et
à la turquie par la même occasion de
violer les droits fondamentaux de ses
citoyens
les droits des femmes les droits des
journalistes des opposants des minorités
notamment religieuses alors je vous pose
la question à tous les deux démocratie
dictature la turquie didier billion
alors dieu oui pour moi c'est évidemment
ce n'était pas une démocratie c'est une
autocratie évidemment suite à ce qui
s'est passé en juillet 2016 cette
tentative de coup d'état
la répression contre les intellectuels
contre les journalistes contre les
fonctionnaires enfin tous ceux qui ne
sont pas d'accord avec erdogan se sont
retrouvés soit en prison ils sont encore
très nombreux aujourd'hui soient limogés
de leurs postes quand il s'agissait par
exemple de fonctionnaires donc ça c'est
un fait on peut aussi considérer que la
liberté d'expression des médias
notamment n'existe plus ou quasiment
plus c'est à dire que les
médias critiques sont infiniment
affaibli et et ont beaucoup de mal à
pouvoir s'imposer dans dans le débat ou
de ce qu'il reste de débats donc là
dessus je pense qu'il n'y a pas débat
pour autant pour ma part je me refuse à
considérer la turquie comme une
dictature si le montrent un sens et je
ne prendrai qu'un exemple parce qu'on
n'est pas là pour simplement discuter de
philosophie politique on est aussi là
pour regarder les faits je me souviens
par exemple il ya maintenant presque
deux ans c'était à la fin du printemps
2010 neuf il ya eu des élections
municipales et nous nous rappelons que
les deux principales villes du pays à
savoir ankara et istanbul qui auparavant
étaient tenus par des responsables de la
ké pé c'est à dire le parti a été fondé
et qui est d'ailleurs toujours dirigée
par monsieur erdogan ont été battus ont
été battus y compris istanbul où il ya
eu un troisième vote à troisième tour si
vous voulez parce que monsieur erdogan
avait récusé la légalité des votes et
elle avait considéré qu'il y avait eu du
bourrage d'urnes singulier paradoxe
oui le problème c'est que lors du
deuxième tour il y avait que je crois de
mémoire vingt ou trente mille bulletins
qui séparaient les deux listes et et au
troisième tour donc celui qui a été
voulue organisé par monsieur redonne il
ya eu je crois de mémoire 800000
différence de vote donc cela prouve que
la société civile turque se saisit de
tous les moyens dans des conditions
infiniment difficile et souvent en butte
à la répression se saisit de tous les
moyens pour résister et avouez quand
même qu'une dictature cité d'été le cas
qui accepterait que les deux principales
villes de son pays à savoir la capitale
économique et les capitales politiques
soient tenues par l'opposition
suit un processus électoral montre bien
qu'on n'est pas dans une situation de
dictature pour autant la question des
droits démocratiques des droits
individuels et collectifs est évidemment
extrêmement pour ne pas dire plus
préoccupant et c'est totalement
condamnable on a évoqué précédemment que
monsieur erdogan avait par exemple
choisi de se retirer de la convention
d'istanbul
c'est un très mauvais signal et tout à
l'heure je pensais que monsieur ardoines
n'avait pas fait preuve de sexisme
à part ce qui s'est passé avec madame
van der leyen et cetera
mais par contre ce que l'on peut
souligner c'est que la conception du
rôle social des femmes de l dans la
bouche de monsieur ardennes dans sa tête
est tout à fait contestable et il faut
le contesté parce qu'ils considèrent que
les fans en turquie en fait doivent être
considérées comme des vers de mère au
foyer et des reproductrices à il l'a dit
à plusieurs reprises il a même déclaré
une fois que des femmes qui n'avaient
pas trois enfants n'étaient pas des
femmes accomplies donc on voit qu'il ya
une morale réactionnaire extrêmement
conservatrice ça oui et c'est à prendre
en ligne de compte et pour autant pour
ma part en tout cas je ne considère pas
que c'est une dictature au sens littéral
de l'adfi dit de la définition de ce
terme
jean françois colosimo nos dictatures en
voit peut-être mais des cta tueur n'ont
pas totalement parce qu'il ya
effectivement une société là on est
d'accord avec les billions de ya une
société turque eux qui résistent
maintenant la turquie est un pays il ya
un siècle d'existence
c'est un pays qui à partir de 1960 a
connu cinq coups d'état militaires qui
ont interrompu la démocratie dans ce
pays avancés ce un coup d'état militaire
atatürk mustafa kemal à l'ast orateurs
le fondateur de cette république avait
voulu même créé un faux partis
d'opposition avant de le supprimer
parce que effectivement y penser que la
turquie n'était pas mûre pour la
démocratie le grand successeur d'atatürk
qu'on le voit comme un continuateur ou
comme je dirais un contradicteur un
rival
cr dogan dans toute la période où il n'y
a pas eu de chef suprême pour incarner
la nation le pays a connu des heures
très très lourde
outre les putschs dont je parlais il ya
eu tout ce rôle de l'état profond qui
est un état qui voit l'état profond
c'est ce milieu qui rassemble les
affairistes les officines l'extrême
droite les services secrets c'est un
pays la turquie qui dans les années 1970
1980 1990 a connu en fait des vagues
d'assassinats politiques
donc si on compte tous les gens qui ont
été mis en prison pour leurs opinions au
cours du 2
remy siècle écoulé mais en fait depuis
1923 si on compte le nombre de meurtres
politiques si on compte le fait que 25%
de la population au moins vis sans droit
de reconnaissance à son identité ce soit
identité ethnique les kurdes ou une
identité religieuse les alevis n'est ce
pas si on considère que les petites
minorités au ce qu'il en reste qui sont
censés être protégés par le traité de
lausanne les juifs les arméniens les
grains que s'en fait des citoyens de
second rang dont l'existence même est
suspendu à l'arbitraire de
l'administration et c'est donc le
problème de la démocratie en turquie ne
date pas d'erdogan
erdogan y ajouter quoi la course aux
plats pouvoir puisqu'il se veut un
deuxième atatürk à anata turque
islamiste et il a tout fait pour obtenir
ses pleins pouvoirs quitte à faire
dérailler des processus électoraux
lorsque comme en 2015 les élections
législatives ont été remises à la suite
d'attentats qui se sont produits dans le
sud est de la turquie et dont personne
ne peut véritablement dire qui sont les
auteurs ou lorsqu'il a voulu empêcher
l'élection d'ailleurs de l'actuel maire
d'istanbul en recourant à divers moyens
qui correspondrait à notre conseil
d'état ou conseil constitutionnel donc
c'est évident que on n'est pas sous une
dictature mais c'est évidemment aussi
qu'on n'est pas dans un pays de liberté
du tout et que toutes les libertés sont
en fait gagner et gagner parfois au prix
du sang en turquie il faut bien le
comprendre
alors on rappelle évidemment ce que tout
le monde sait c'est que la turquie est
membre de l'otan et et d'ailleurs
pendant la guerre froide
on peut pas dire que l'absence de
liberté en turquie et ni même les
successifs putsch militaire nous aide
beaucoup gêné à ce moment là c'était la
turquie est écossais comme un allié
fiable mais aujourd'hui on se pose la
question et on voit bien que très
souvent si s'il ya des heurts entre les
européens et les chefs d'état européens
et notamment le président de la
république française et avec recep
tayyip erdogan
c'est justement parce qu'on se demande
aux faux si c'est véritablement un allié
ou si ça ne serait pas devenu notre
ennemi alors c'est la question que je
vous pose est au fond c'est la question
dont parlait
nos deux représentants de l'europe avec
air douanes en essayant d'apaiser les
tensions
au fond il lui demandait est-ce qu'on
est toujours amis ou est ce qu'on est en
train de devenir ennemis alors votre
votre réponse didier billion amis ou
ennemis la turquie aujourd'hui alors
selon la célèbre formule que vous
connaissez bien les états n'ont pas
d'amis donc des intérêts bon c'est une
boutade de ma part et je pense que poser
la question ainsi est un peu binaire
vous me pardonnerez je pense qu'il faut
au contraire développer une autre vision
j'espère que nous serons le plus amis
possible avec le peuple au tueur ça
c'est une évidence je suis très attaché
à ce pays depuis fort longtemps
j'y vais souvent j'y ai beaucoup d'amis
et mes amis sont souvent dans des
conditions difficiles aujourd'hui du
point de vue de l'exercice de leur libre
pensée de leur pensée critique mais pour
autant ce qui me semble important c'est
le rôle objectifs géostratégiques de la
turquie donc pour moi la turquie c'est
avant tout un partenaire à partenaire
compliqué à partenaires difficiles avec
lequel nous avons toujours eu beaucoup
de mal à à discuter et à dialoguer à
négocier parce qu'on a du mal à prendre
ce pays
on a du mal à le percevoir ça c'est une
certitude
et ça rend compliqué le dial mais pas
seulement d'ailleurs avec monsieur
ardoines c'est beaucoup plus anciens
alors il ya des moments où il ya des
rapprochements tout à fait spectaculaire
et de mon point de vue positif avec ce
pays
et puis il ya d'autres moments et nous
sommes plutôt dans cette séquence où les
choses se tendent considérablement
donc c'est parce que je crois que les
états peuvent poursuivre des projets
différents qui à certains moments les
éloigne mais pour autant considérer que
la turquie est un ennemi est une erreur
de perspective total je ne vois pas en
quoi la nature qui auraient des
velléités sur l'union européenne par
exemple donc qu'elle exerce sur certains
dossiers un chantage à l'encontre de
l'union européenne
je pense bien sûr au dossier des des
migrants des réfugiés qui sont quand
même près de 4 millions sur son sol et
jeudis de ce point de vue là hommage à
la turquie d'avoir su accepter
accueillir dans des conditions
difficiles s'est réfugié monsieur
erdogan par exemple l'année dernière au
mois de février dernier
un peu plus d'un an à exercer une sorte
de chantage qui n'est pas acceptable
ce n'est pas la bonne méthode de
disputer donc content je pense que les
européens auraient tout intérêt à
modifier leur perception à se placer en
perspective à se placer en positif à
l'égard de ce pays en mettant sur la
table un certain nombre de dossiers dont
il nous faut discuter ce que nous avons
un intérêt commun à traiter
conjointement ces dossiers mais pour
autant il y à d'autres aspects d'autres
dossiers sur lequel nous devons marquer
notre fermeté et c'est ce que nous
n'arrivons pas à faire ou très
difficilement
c'est à dire qu'il ya toujours une
ambiguïté entre l'acceptation de des
exigences de monsieur redonne et puis
par moments vous me pardonnez
l'expression des coups de gueule et on
se fâche alors les coups de gueule
d'ailleurs ils sont des deux côtés ils
ne sont pas que du côté de monsieur
erdogan est encore une fois certaines
des expressions qui l'utilisent à
l'encontre de dirigeants européens ne
sont pas acceptables c'est des choses
entre états intelligent qui devrait
l'être
ce n'est pas acceptable mais il faut là
aussi dépassé légumes des choses pour
aller à l'essentiel
aujourd'hui oui ou non l'union
européenne s'ils tentaient que celle-ci
veuille se doter d'une politique
extérieure commune c'est une question
qu'on peut se poser
mais si elle se dote de ce projet oui ou
non avons nous un intérêt à accentuer
nos relations avec la turquie
avons-nous oui ou non un intérêt à en
faire un véritable partenaire y compris
du point de vue des intérêts européens
dans la région dans une région
infiniment compliqué le caucase le
moyen-orient l'afrique du nord et cetera
la méditerranée orientale
je pense que nous reparlerons de tous
ces dossiers il me semble que oui nous
avons un intérêt à coopérer
encore une fois c'est compliqué c'est
difficile c'est plus facile à énoncer
qu'à réaliser mais pour autant en termes
stratégiques
je considère pour ma part qu'il faut
renforcer par tous les moyens un
véritable partenariat avec la turquie
donc je ne la considère évidemment pas
comme une ennemie et j'espère qu'elle
deviendra véritablement une amie mais
pour ce faire il faut qu'on en parle des
go à ego il faut que nous sachions poser
toutes les questions sur la table entre
partenaires il faut tout se dire sinon
il va il restera des zones d'ombré qui
ne seront pas élucidé qui ne nous
permettrons pas de nous projeter vers
l'avenir
eh bien on va répondre à toutes ces
questions mais juste après une pause je
vous retrouve après laffaire argos
comment ce family office at il réussi à
provoquer un nouveau vent de panique sur
les marchés mais aussi des pertes
massives pour plusieurs l établissement
bancaire utilisé l'effet de levier pour
gagner de l'argent en bourse ça se fait
tous les jours
en fait c'est toute cette incitation à
toujours pouvoir gagner plus avec
l'argent gratuit de la fed qui a
finalement poussé nombre de banques à
suivre monsieur rendent c'est quelque
chose qui nous a emmenés dans une
catastrophe en 2007 et en 2008
tous les tous les crédits ficelé goldman
sachs et morgan stanley était évidemment
pas au courant les uns des autres
quartiers gosses avaient autant
d'engagements à droite à gauche et c'est
en principe de l'opacité de la chose
peut l'annoncer dès maintenant vous
aurez des archers gosses en x 10
[Musique]
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
de son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage à abandonner l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une europe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
on reprend notre débat sur la turquie
avec jean-françois que le six mots
l'auteur du livre le sabre et le turban
aux éditions du surf et avec didier
billion qui lui publié géopolitique des
mondes arabes aux éditions eyrolles
alors didier billion avez la parole
elle est à vous jean françois que le 6
mo i là il a bien posé le problème à
savoir est ce qu'on peut au fond se
réconcilier avec la turquie
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous moi je
sais gré a dit les billions de
d'exprimer des choses des sentiments que
je partage il y à un peuple turcs eux
qui est tout à fait admirable de vertus
d'hospitalité il y à un pays qui est
magnifique surtout avec l'empilement je
dirais architectural grec bise entre
arméniens et les terrains qui ne
participent pas comme le déclare le
ministère turc de la culture de la
grande civilisation turcot anatolienne
mais le peuple et stylisation qui se
sont déroulées dans cet orient occident
et que la turquie actuelle a tendance à
nier
n'est ce pas comme ennemi son histoire
le génocide des arméniens par exemple
qui de 1915 commis par les jeunes turcs
dont était atteint turc même s'ils
n'étaient pas liés au génocide puisqu'il
est un héros de guerre au même moment
mais c'est bien cette loi qui régente
l'amnésie turc et on n'est pas européen
par exemple lorsque en fait on est
incapable de ce retour critique sur soi
d'espacé certainement l' empêchement
majeur donc cette turquie dans laquelle
il les intellectuels tout à fait
admirable et qui sont souvent la
souffrance peut-être même les mêmes amis
voyez
oublions donc cette turquie là je dirais
oui bien sûr mais c'est pas la turquie
dont on parle
la turquie dont on parle aujourd'hui
c'est une turquie qui est extrêmement
offensive
cette turquie qui est extrêmement
offensive eh bien elle elle fait quoi
elle réalise le voeu d'atatürk qui
réclame est en fait la possession d'alep
et de mossoul c'est à dire la bande
côtière qui articule le monde anatolien
le monde turquie puis le monde levantin
le monde arabe
c'est une turquie qui encore une fois
hausse le ton sur chypre envahi en 1974
par les généraux turcs ce n'était pas
une période de paie donc semble-t-il à
cette période là aussi l'espace c'est
une turquie qui en libye joue pour le
gouvernement provisoire qui est de
tendance islamiste contre le marriage
and after qui est soutenu au passage par
la russie et la france
c'est une turquie qui se mêle à beyrouth
de d'affaires qui sont particulièrement
anti française parce que c'est une
vieille histoire
le grand turk et la france c'est le
problème de la maîtrise de la delà de la
maîtrise à visiter rennais orientale et
puis à côté de ça il ya évidemment cette
turquie qui s'allie avec bakou c'est le
vieux projet des jeunes turcs n'est ce
pas un grand espace turcophones qui
irait jusqu'à l'azerbaïdjan qui est
réparé de l'azerbaïdjan jusqu'au à tous
les ce temps les ouzbékistan des
kirghizes distant et autres qui auraient
peut-être que jusqu'aux ouïghoure de
chine
tout ça évidemment il ya un côté
fantasmagorique mais il ya eu une guerre
le haut karabagh est vidé de ces
arméniens et le haut karabagh éviter de
serre maignien par des miliciens syrien
transport ancien jihadiste transportés
par la turquie sur place voyez et puis
il ya évidemment les manoeuvres en mer
egée et qui menace la grèce la grèce
dont la turquie continue d'être pour le
coup l'ennemi l'ennemi fondamentale donc
tout cela accompagné en plus de discours
insensé et au rôle en génocidaire fait
que la turquie aujourd'hui n'est pas
votre ami
elle n'a pas intérêt à ce que notre
ennemi mais un manifeste en fait une
forme d'adversité et dans cette
adversité effectivement se pose là votre
question frédéric taddeï celles de
l'otan l'otan c'est une alliance qui
avait été pensée contre l'urss elle
aurait dû disparaître avec la fin de
l'urss
on a voulu la maintenir parce que
effectivement je dirais que le camp
occidental n'admet pas que la russie
reste une grande puissance nucléaire
bon aujourd'hui erdogan se souvenant
peut-être de la longue histoire de l'
empire byzantin de la longue histoire de
l'empiré ottoman se rapproche
effectivement de blagnac poutine et lui
achète des armes
c'est une vérité alors est-ce que dès
lors que l'otan se veut tout à fait
hostile à la bastide monsieur poutine
lorsque monsieur erdogan qui est dans
l'otan pactisent avec monsieur poutine
est ce que monsieur erdogan et dans
l'otan ou et avec monsieur poutine c'est
une question pour l'otan mais l'otan
c'est un modèle aussi totalement dépassé
et finalement il faut dire merci à
monsieur erdogan
il nous montre que l'union européenne ne
tient pas debout il nous montre que
l'otan ne tient pas debout
et pendant ce temps là comme nous
restons et bailly eh bien il fait son
shopping
il fait son shopping au levant en
méditerranée dans le caucase et peut
certainement demain à travers certes eu
une influence beaucoup moins militaire
dans les balkans alors cela dure
vis-à-vis de deux lettres divers poutine
et de la russie erding est aussi en
train de copiner avec le président
ukrainien qui n'est pas franchement le
meilleur ami de vladimir poutine
et dans le cas du haut-karabakh ils se
sont carrément opposées puisque poutine
était favorable aux armenia et et et
redonne aux azéri donc on voit bien il
ya eu d'ailleurs récemment une une
couverture de courrier international qui
montrait airlines extrêmement isolé sans
véritablement de d'allier ou en tout cas
capable de se fâcher avec tout ses
alliés un désert après les autres alors
la parole et à didier billion parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à répondre à
aa jean-françois que le si beau oui
alors là je pense que nous sommes en
radicale des accords effectivement tous
les deux alors sauf sur un point c'est à
dire est ce que l'otan encore une
légitimité une réalité de l'existence
non je suis d'accord je pense que cette
organisation aurait dû disparaître après
la fin du pacte de varsovie sur ce point
d'accord sûr
tout le reste est en désaccord donc pour
aller à l'essentiel
jean françois colossimo qui est un homme
de culture et un historien à nous fait
beaucoup de références à l'histoire sauf
que par exemple il nous dit que le
projet d'atatürk c'était de récupérer à
l'épée mossoul
moi j'ai moins qu'ils nous sortent des
déclarations des discours de atatürk sur
cet aspect en tout cas aujourd'hui
en 2000 ce lien il est clair qu'il ya
une chose qui est oui oui d'accord
attendez je vous ai pas interrompu chers
amis je pense que aujourd'hui en 2021
la turquie ne veut ni à l'est ni mossoul
et voudrait-elle elle n'y parviendrais
pas de toute façon car ni les syriens ni
les irakiens ne laisserai ferait faire
une telle chose
jean françois colosimo a évoqué le cas
de la libye
mais c'est tout à fait intéressant vous
dites que la france et la russie
souhaitaient haftar oui ça me pose moi
est un singulier problème c'est que la
france est membre du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu et que le conseil de sécurité
de l'onu avait porté sur les fonts
baptismaux et soutenait théoriquement le
gouvernement de fayyad et le sa rage
or en réalité dans la réalité la dure
réalité des faits effectivement la
france taaf tard donc il ya là quand
même une contradiction est ce que
monsieur macron n'a pas du tout du tout
apprécié c'est que l'intervention
militaire de la turquie en libye à la
demande du gouvernement légitime reconnu
par l'onu c'est-à-dire le gouvernement
l'ex gouvernement de faillite elle
s'arrache et d'ailleurs ça a été
souligné ce week-end même par assane
sall années l'ancien envoyé spécial de
l'onu en libye qui a clairement déclaré
ai expliqué que la turquie c'est avait
conçu cette intervention militaire dans
la stricte légalité du droit
international c'est quand même
intéressant et c'est la france qui s'est
totalement trouvé avec prise à
contre-pied c'est à dire que mon du
conseil de sécurité a le super un
général de type robel et donc elle s'est
retrouvée bas du côté de ceux qui ont
perdu à ce stade en tout cas parce que
la libye n'est pas déstabilisé du côté
de ceux qui avaient perdu des parts de
marché sur le terrain libyen si vous
me pardonner cette expression un peu
triviale donc là pour le coup la turquie
a joué plutôt habilement yat-il volonté
de la turquie de s'implanter durablement
en libye bah oui sont pas totalement
naïf
nous savons que la libye est doté de
deux gisements d'hydrocarbures de très
grande importance nous savons qu'il ya
une histoire avec la libye de longue
date et je ne remonte pas du tout l
empire ottoman est donc évidemment la
turquie qui encore une fois comme je le
disais initialement et tu as une
politique d' influence veut tenter en
tout cas de s'implanter en lui ce qui ne
veut pas dire conquérir la libye ce qui
n'aurait aucun sens
donc si le président macron pendant
quelques mois était si remonté contre la
turquie c'est je pense justement à cause
de ce dossier libyen
on s'est pris les pieds dans le tapis en
tout cas monsieur mac on s'est pris les
pieds dans le tapis et a été humiliée en
réalité parce que la france qui avait
beaucoup de velléités d' influence sur
la libye aujourd'hui se retrouvent comme
une simple spectatrice sans aucune marge
de manoeuvre est au contraire c'est
d'une part la la turquie et qui a un
rôle très important et par ailleurs la
russie qu'il ne faut pas oublier et
j'espère je souhaite de tout mon coeur
que l'onu puisse reprendre des
initiatives digne de ce nom pour tenter
de stabiliser enfin ce pays qui n'en
peut plus donc on peut multiplier les
exemples mais ce que je veux simplement
évoqué c'est que on peut parler syrie on
peut parler libye on peut parler haut
karabagh on peut parler méditerranée
orientale
le problème c'est que jean françois
colossimo mais tulsa dans le même paquet
et c'est une erreur de méthode c'est à
dire que les raisons qui poussent la
turquie est intervenu à intervenir
militairement nollen dans le nord de la
syrie c'est à cause de la question kurde
et ça c'est une réalité et je pense et
je les écris à de nombreuses reprises
que la turquie a tort de gérer la
question cure de cette façon il n'y aura
pas de solution militaire la question
kurde c'est uniquement par la
négociation politique on y parviendra en
libye je n'y reviens pas je l'évoqué sur
la méditerranée orientale
oui je critique pour ma part la forme
les déclarations belliqueuses très
occupante inutilement agressif de
monsieur douanes
oui trois fois oui mais pour autant sur
le fond du dossier de la méditerranée
orientale
alors je considère que la turquie à
quelques légers
limité à revendiquer sa part de
possibilités d'exploitation des
richesses de gaz qui se trouve en
offshore
on ne peut pas exclure la turquie de
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
de la méditerranée orientale
il suffit de regarder nos cartes enfin
considéré que la grèce est l'ennemi
héréditaire
je récuse aussi cet aspect cette
compréhension des choses je ne prendrai
ça doit parler à jean françois colossimo
qui est un historien de la fameuse
visite de venizelos
accueillis par atatürk à ankara au début
des années 30
quelques années après le grand échange
qui avait eu lui des populations entre
la grèce et à la turquie
ils se sont rencontrés ils se sont
réconciliés parce que c'était deux
hommes d'état
ce n'était pas des petits politiciens
donc voilà c'est la preuve
enfin un élément de réflexion qui me
fait considérer qu'il n'ya pas une aide
inexpugnable entre les grecs et les
turcs ça c'est une vision de l'esprit
en réalité ces deux peuples ont
tellement de points communs qu'il
devrait pouvoir se réconcilier enfin
parce qu'il y a des poils de divergence
incontestable
enfin et dernière chose sur la russie le
mot peut le fait que la nature qui
pactisent avec la russie je trouve que
le terme est mal choisi oui il ya une
fluidité des relations entre la entre
moscou et ankara aujourd'hui mais
n'oublions pas qu'en syrie qu au
karabagh et qu'en libye la les turcs et
les russes se retrouvent dans des camps
opposés mais la différence avec toute
une série d'autres états c'est que la
russie et la turquie sont suffisamment
sage et ont une vision suffisamment
comment dirais-je décontractée de leurs
relations pour qu'il trouve des terrains
d'entente alors pour autant est-ce que
c'est une trahison à l'égard de l'otan
on peut en discuter mais pour terminer
il y à la fameuse histoire des missiles
russes des système de missiles
antimissiles au risque les fameux x 400
qui ont été achetés par la turquie qui
ont été déployés en sur le sol turc en
juillet 2019 mais qui depuis leur ne
sont pas activés et ça c'est à mon avis
très important il faut le souligner donc
si les occidentaux
l'otan ou si l'union européenne ou sur
les états unis parce qu'il faudra
peut-être parler des etats-unis a
accepté de négocier enfin clairement des
des besoins de la turquie en termes de
défense dans une région un peu compliqué
peut-être alors les skates sens
reprendra le chemin de moscou
donc voyez il faut voir les choses de
façon un peu décontracté il ne faut pas
céder au raisonnement binaire
les choses sont toujours beaucoup plus
compliqué et les relations d'état à état
sont toujours très très très fluctuante
parce qu'évidemment les rapports de
force se modifie au fur et à mesure que
l'histoire évolue en françois colossimo
bas gérer que my fair italie vous disiez
que hot que erdogan est très seul sur la
scène internationale non il à didier
billion ne sais pas avec lui au moins
comme avocat et comme avocats soutenus
qui voudraient certainement qu'on soit
décontracté et on va se mettre à l'école
des arméniens qui vivent terrés à
istanbul pour c est contracté des kurdes
qui sont persécutés dans le sud-est de
la turquie on va se mettre à l'école des
chypriotes grecs on va se mettre à
l'école des arméniens du haut karabagh
on sera tous décontractée très très
heureux d'être décontracté et on
comprendra qu'en fait si erdogan n'est
pas gentil c'est un peu notre faute
parce qu'on n'est pas assez gentil avec
lui c'est ce que j'ai entendu un peu
plus dense vous avez dit cher ami à par
rapport à ça il est évident que non bien
sûr que atatürk eux voulaient allaitent
et mossoul ce sont des villes symboles
il voulait la bande territoriales
encore une fois sur laquelle erdogan
aujourd'hui à des troupes bon didier
billion louer les turcs d'accueillir 3
millions 603 millions 600 mille 4
millions de 2,2 de réfugiés syriens sur
leur territoire et ça avantage beaucoup
erdogan aussi il faut le dire il ya un
effort valeureux de la population turque
effectivement mais il ya aussi eu de
grands efforts des populations la hac
n'est ce pas à l'égard des migrants
mais bon en attendant ça arrange erdogan
que la frontière soit brouillée parce
que contrairement à ce que pensent
certainement dit billon non la turquie
n'a jamais véritablement voilà
considérer les frontières gagné lors du
traité de lausanne
comme des frontières minimale en quelque
sorte c'est la fameuse affaire il en
parlait au début de l'émission du
sandjak d'alexandrette c'est-à-dire ce
coude qui fait le coin de la
méditerranée en face de chypre et qui
est en fait le littoral syrien et dans
laquelle dans dans lequel ressort donc
territoriales
la turquie a agité les populations comme
elle l'a fait plus tard à chypre et à
provoquer en fait une politique du fait
accompli devant la devant lequel fait
accompli nous nous sommes couchés
nous français en 1938 en espérant que la
turquie nous rejoindre est cette fois ci
contre l'allemagne la différence de l'
empire ottoman en 1914
effectivement la la la turquie s'est
rallié au plan des alliés né en février
ça c'est voir la vérité de l'histoire et
nous avons sacrifié une région dont nous
avons chassé les arméniens survivants du
génocide et vous auront livré des
populations foncièrement arabe
finalement une domination turque mais
comme le dit des deux didier billion qui
suit la géographie nationale turque la
province du à t as pas qui est en fait
en fait une pure invention turc donc de
ce point de vue là non bien sûr que non
on peut pondéré toutes les choses etc on
peut aussi penser que emmanuel macron
agit mal mais didier billion la femme
m'a convaincu de dire du bien des
manuels macro est en soi c'est déjà un
miracle
il est évident que emmanuel macron a été
le seul à s'opposer les vacances de
pouvoir aux états unis
poutine de son côté mener son propre jeu
et c'est normal n'est ce pas emmanuel
macron a été le seul à s'opposer nous
sommes avait quasiment contacts
militaires avec cette espèce d' aventure
tout à fait franc tasma gorik turque
dans les eaux territoriales de pays qui
ne sont pas la turquie n'est ce pas bon
on a osé tout ça on a dit non et je
crois que la sphère de libye on peut
peut-être classe et l'onu on rend des
organisations que didier violent et
moi-même considérons qu'elles n'ont pas
grand sens comme l'otan certainement un
peu l'union européenne d'un extrait -
d'accord que moi mais la france joue son
jeu bien sûr bien sûr que la france joue
son jeu pourquoi la france jouerait tel
le
la turquie n'est ce pas et la turquie
joue son jeu le problème qui est bien
c'est que le problème qu'il y a c'est
que cette opposition en militaires année
particulièrement mais étendu désormais
au caucase qui touchait balkans cette
opposition avait été constitutive de la
conscience européenne n'est ce pas parce
qu'il s'est agit véritablement d'arrêter
le grand turk même si on a pu avoir un
moment des relations diplomatiques forte
avec lui mais la diplomatie la guerre
vont de pair et didier billion sera
certainement à quoi répond là dessus
donc aujourd'hui nous avons quoi nous
avons 1 1 1
un autocrate des débiles on l'a dit nous
sommes d'accord là dessus nous avons un
autocrate qui croit son heure
international arrivé n'est ce pas
si ce n'est que le jeu l'international
c'est pas la turquie
on n'est pas en prison qui on veut n'est
ce pas en exil pas qui on veut on
décrète pas des lois absurdes comme on
veut et donc ils se plaignent réel et se
cognant au réel ayant vu effectivement
vladimir poutine ramasser la mise dans
le caucase parce que le véritable
victorieux de cette guerre sale c'est
qu'à mener la turquie avec des abeilles
dont c'est la guerre poutine parce que
pour la première fois des troupes russes
sont de retour au centre du caucase en
azerbaïdjan monsieur erdogan a fait des
gains il ay là il a une route qui lui
permet de rejoindre bac pro directement
il longe désormais l'iran et c'est très
bien mais le vainqueur c'est pas lui
c'est vladimir poutine est de notre côté
il a vu joe biden arrivé au pouvoir aux
états unis et il faut bien savoir que
les démocrates
ankama je dirais recueilli les
néoconservateurs la grande école
géopolitique des néoconservateurs qui
était un peu à la rue depuis la fin du
deuxième mandat de georges d'abord lieu
bouche d'un clown à leur tour à une
amérique qui a des prétentions
n'est ce pas je dirais des prétentions
de projection de sa puissance entre les
deux ans travaille à poutine et joe
biden monsieur erdogan est obligé de se
retourner vers l'europe
n'est ce pas d'autant plus que
lui qui a été le père de la prospérité
il est connu comme ça pour les paris
turquie n'est pas connu comme le nouveau
sultan le deuxième à nature il a su
accompagner le développement du tigres
anatoliens qui est aujourd'hui à l'arrêt
donc la livre turque la mode et turcs
décroche l'économie dans un état
catastrophique bien sûr qu'il a besoin
de l'argent de l'europe et bien sûr que
l'europe est très peu morale de se
soumettre en fait à un maître chanteur
qui garde pour otage des réfugiés dont
l'europe ne veut pas bien entendu mais
la logique des maîtres chanteurs est
connu c'est que une fois qu'on a passé à
la caisse on y passe une deuxième puis
une troisième fois
d'ailleurs c'est pour cela puisqu'on va
démarrer là dessus que cet incident
protocolaire je crois un véritable
incident parce que il y avait quand même
3 milliards d'euros à la clé un
versement et c'est beaucoup d'argent à
la clé des visas pour les turcs à la clé
donc c'était une négociation qui était
très importante pour erdogan
mais dans le même temps ça n'a pas
empêché de continuer à réprimer au sein
de son pays parmi les dix amiraux qu'il
a fait à mettre au garde à vous il ya le
fameux théoricien de la merde le la
domination turque sur toutes les mers
qui l'entourent la mer egée la mer
caspienne la mer de marmara etc
c'est normalement cette 1ère d'organiste
puisque l'air d'organes a récupéré cette
théorie géopolitique mais non il a osé
critiquer le raïs le patron le chef
n'est ce pas et donc cette amiable s'y
retrouvent et qu'ils étaient par par la
police sur un point d'ailleurs je dirais
qu'il ne touchait même pas aux
fondamentaux de l'air d'organismes donc
je pense que aujourd'hui effectivement
on a les turcs et nous mêmes avons un
problème là dessus avec un homme qu'il
ne faut surtout pas prendre pour un
idiot
un homme qui est beaucoup moins impulsif
qui me paraît ni un homme qui est dans
cette logique qui était celle du
fondateur de cette république ou
contactez mal dit atatürk qui est dans
la logique en fait
dudu du souverain qui incarne la nation
la came nation est promise à un destin
messianique
il y a de cela au treffendel aventures
de recep tayyip erdogan
alors il nous reste un peu moins de cinq
minutes
alors réponse de didier billion oui
j'essaye de vous garder du temps pour
tous les deux bah écoutez moi j'ai un
désaccord radical sur les tréfonds de la
nature moi je ne suis pas psychologue
dont j'ai un petit peu de mal à cerner
le tréfonds des âmes des peuples c'est
encore plus compliqué que le tréfonds de
l'âme d'un individu et donc je pense
qu'il ne faut pas se placer dans la
perspective d'une volonté expansionniste
ni de l'ata turc alors si atatürk à
bienne une obsession c'est qu'il a
constitué la république de turquie qui
était dans un état absolument ruiné qui
était dans un état absolument lamentable
après avoir connu les quatre ans de
guerre de la première guerre mondiale
puis trois ans de guerre civile
donc c'était un pic était littéralement
à genoux donc la seule préoccupation de
mustafa kemal atatürk était de
reconstruire une nation oui c'est vrai
ça c'était de construire la république
est tenu de lui donner les moyens de de
se réaffirmer sur le champ international
et d'ailleurs on en a beaucoup parlé ces
derniers jours il était parvenu en 1936
symboliquement par la signature de la
convention de montreux qui a été l'objet
de l'arrestation de ces dix amiraux qui
a été évoquée précédemment donc mustafa
kemal atatürk avait sûrement beaucoup de
défauts probablement il avait aussi à
mon avis beaucoup de qualités mais en
tout cas pas le défaut de vouloir se
projeter dans une politique
expansionniste
enfin dernière chose puisqu'il nous
reste très peu de temps je crois que air
doan pour sa part est quelqu'un qui
n'est pas capable de se projeter sur le
moyen ou sur le long terme c'est un
homme de coups avec un p à la fin c'est
un homme qui a un sens aigu de la
réaction de la réactivité et à settat un
pragmatique
c'est un homme qui a un sens politique
incroyable souvent pour le pire on le
voit d'ailleurs quand il s'agit
d'analyser la question des droits
démocratiques des des libertés
individuelles que nous avons évoqué tout
à l'heure mais j'ai un ami proche un ami
turquie est un opposant qui est un
démocrate turquie et qui dit souvent que
quand ils voient erdo années poutine
discuté et bien il ne peut s'empêcher de
voir le jour
des chèques qui est poutine ans le curé
et qui tu joues toujours avec deux trois
quatre coups d'avancé et a contrario et
redonne est un joueur de talent ou là un
joueur de trictrac vous savez ce jeu
qu'on pratique dans tout le moyen-orient
c'est un jeu sur aussi un une base
envers eux une table et qui est avec des
pions et avec des bd et quand on lance
les dés on peut remettre tout en
question d'un coup et bah c'est ce que
fait monsieur redonne il tente des coups
des fois il lui réussit des films ne le
réussisse pas mais la seule chose que je
veux souligner c'est le fait que en
réalité
erdogan n'est pas animé par un projet
panislamisme en turquie ou que sais-je
encore contrairement à ce que disait
jean françois colossimo aujourd'hui les
paons turkistan turquie milson
groupusculaire il n'aurait pas non plus
rien il oui oui mais ça il faudrait
pouvoir poursuivre la discussion y
compris même le parti d'extrême droite
le parti d'action nationaliste qui est
en alliance avec monsieur redonne
aujourd'hui et bien n'a même plus ses
velléités c'était celle de monsieur
turckheim qui est mort depuis maintenant
fort longtemps
donc voyez il faut éviter de fantasmer
sur la réalité la pure réalité des faits
s'en tenir aux faits c'est déjà
suffisamment compliqué se dotait d'une
ligne de fermeté et de dialogue à
l'égard de la turquie
je dis bien la turquie y compris ses
aspects les plus officiels parce qu'on
est bien obligé d'avoir cet
interlocuteur ne pas se mettre à genoux
ne pas céder à cette exigence mais se
placer tout jean perspective de projets
concrets commun parce que c'est comme ça
qu'à mon avis nous pourrons refonder
c'est le maître mot refonder une
relation digne de ce nom avec la turquie
une minute jean françois colossimo
écouter gerber a beaucoup de qualités
mais il est quelques aux politiciens il
a mené dans les dépêches
donc il croit que je parle de l'âme des
peuples gens parlent pas mais il ya des
invariants un de ces invariants qui est
très claire un de ces bars un soir à
lyon qui est très clair c'est que
lorsque erdogan a reconverti
sainte-sophie en mosquée le presse a été
donnée aux patrons de la diane est le
ministère tentaculaire des cultes et il
n'a pas fait un prêche sur le coran mais
sur la conquête
donc bien sûr que cette conquête elle
prend différents aspects bien sûr que je
les écris il fait semblant d'être
organise la crise semblant d'être
panturque
il sert une ambition d'un pays qui ne
peut pas aller sans un chef parce que ce
pays n'a pas été reconstruit gérard
billon en 1923 comme ça vous a échappé
il a été purement construit et ça reste
une construction totalement artificielle
parce que cette construction
artificielle pour se survivre a besoin
d'être cannibales et elle demeure
qu'habite cannibale par exemple des
kurdes
encore aujourd'hui je remercie tous les
deux d'avoir vais participer à ce débat
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]